so thank you so much everyone for tuning
in to our third annual panel on
diversity at informs i'm alexandra i'm a
senior software development manager in
scott which stands for supply and chain
optimization technologies and i'll be
leading today's chat with our panelists
from across scott and they are a truly a
remarkable group of people and i'm sure
you will all enjoy hearing about their
experiences
so first of all um we all want to
welcome and congratulate the recipients
of the very first amazon scott
fellowship who are watching this panel
today congratulations
this fellowship represents amazon's
commitment to proving representation in
the professional pipeline of operations
research management science and
analytics analytics research
we hope you're all enjoying the
conference and i know that the scot team
members are looking forward to
connecting with you all directly at the
networking sessions so thank you for
being here
let's start with a note on what
innovation and diversity mean to amazon
innovation is really at core of
everything that amazon does so we say
that every day is a day one meaning that
we strive to think big come up with new
and bold ideas dare to try new things
and also we allow ourselves sometimes to
fail because if we never fail then we're
probably being a little too safe in our
thinking
ultimately we always want to learn
explore and be curious
and we realize that new ideas
prerequisites for innovation and
diversity of our people is key to
bringing in these fresh perspectives and
challenging our thinking
related to that
amazon has recently introduced two new
leadership principles which are expected
to guide the organization at all levels
the goal of striving to be the world's
best employer and a positive force in
our communities and fostering an
environment of inclusion at workplace
and making sure that everyone feels
comfortable to bring their authentic
self to work is an essential part of
this commitment
so before we dive into the questions for
our panel i just wanted to give our
audiences a brief overview of different
themes in scott and the type of
optimization problems they're working on
so i'm myself and from forecasting and
we use machine learning to forecast
demand for old products sold on amazon
around the globe
and it's a very interesting problem
space because we need to consider
different factors such as local holidays
seasonal variations prime membership as
well as unexpected events such as covet
or
an artist winning award
fulfillment optimization team forecasts
the need for transportation they
optimize the delivery network and they
compute the most efficient way to
deliver purchases to customers
inventory planning and control team
determine how much of each product is
needed at each location
and they want to ensure that our
products are available to customers at
the lowest cost
optimal sourcing system managers apply
and they find ways to work around any
supply disruptions
so i will now turn it to our panelists
to tell us a bit about themselves
and let's start with a question for each
one of you please tell us how long
you've been at amazon and what do you do
now and how does your background help
you to be successful
thanks alexandra i'll kick it off first
so i joined amazon in october of 2016 as
part of the global mild team
uh the global mile team is responsible
for building transportation products and
solutions for sellers and internal
amazon divisions that move inventory and
customer orders across our hard borders
now hard border typically is
as you all know what has happened
recently between well recently in the
last year between uk and europe uh with
creating a hard import and export border
between
the uk and continental europe with
brexit
this team started from scratch across
across different job families mostly
focusing on supply chain
experts and people that understand the
cross-border space
but we soon realized that optimization
of volumes routings
different types of orders are going to
be critical for a competitive advantage
in the cross-border space and therefore
started investing more resources in
simulation and machine learning as key
differentiators to plan and execute our
shipments across the borders and as a
result we've evolved from a product and
program team to more of a scientific
team that gets involved in optimization
across the world thank you
okay
in my case i joined amazon two years ago
coming from a background in machine
learning technology and more recently
consumer finance
my team and i we focus were responsible
for producing the long-term
aggregate forecast demand forecast for
amazon
this forecast is super useful for our
teams uh in operations and finance where
they use it to make long-term financial
decisions investment decisions and
planning
so this is an interesting problem
because it's not only a time series
problem but this is a problem where
we need to look into the signals that
influence that the the dynamics of that
demand right and those sickness can be
external to amazon or internals like you
know the state and the health of our
supply chain
thank you
hi
my name is william pachon i joined
amazon seven years ago to lead the
science team for the amazon last smaller
federations since that time the team has
grown from a single or scientists to
over 60 covering a wide variety of
disputes
including optimization machine learning
ai statistics simulation and many others
in my team we developed the models which
efficiently deliver publishers from the
lead station to the postulatory step
and these models includes in all the way
from capacity planning scheduling
exploration planning cloud planning
assignment dispatch control optimization
as well as inferring all the inputs that
are used
to run these months i have been
affiliated to impulse for the past 20
years
i think that just leaves me um so i'm
stephanie collette i've been with amazon
eight years i started right after an mba
program
um i actually joined in our fulfillment
center network so i i my first role was
actually in
an fc uh leading teams um i would like
to say my first role i was actually
walking 13 miles a day
and so it's a lot of fun a good chance
to really understand how our physical
processes work
i spent four years in the fcs and then
moved to our supply chain
organization
and so now i leave our sourcing team
which is part of optimal sourcing
systems
as alexander talked about
our goal is to
basically maximize the amount of
inventory or supply that we're able to
get from our vendors
and to reduce the indian supply chain
costs so i now lead a team a
multifunctional team made up of kind of
software product science
all focused on optimizing our indent
supply chain and building software that
kind of scales and automates our
interactions with our vendors
great thank you everyone so to me it's
really interesting to hear about all
this cross-disciplinary work that is
taking place in your domain and
i want to ask you related to that when
you think of diversity what comes to
mind for you and what does it mean to
you and how do you apply it as a leader
alexandra i'll take the first stab at
that question
uh diversity to me means we give equal
access to everyone which in turn gives
us the opportunity to build real world
solutions
at the heart of global mile is the whole
world and we have learned that it is
essential for our teams to have diverse
backgrounds to consider different
solutions that impact our sellers and
our customers with varying degrees of
access to resources
our teams develop solutions they
intentionally bring this into the
conversation to influence the design and
what success ultimately looks like
therefore access to people from a
variety of university and disciplines
allows allows us to achieve this exact
goal
i can add a bit to that too so i'm i
would consider myself a passionate
advocate for diversity equity and
inclusion i mean i'm actually the
executive sponsor for uh de ni
in the scot organization more broadly um
i work with the the leadership team and
scott to
um come up with our strategic direction
our goals and initiatives um each year
et cetera um for me it's about uh
one having uh diverse perspectives uh
that match our customers um that match
our um
the kind of broader employee-based base
at amazon
and match kind of the
our suppliers as well um so that we are
building solutions that that work kind
of end-to-end from
upstream vendors down to the end
customers um i think
we
we couldn't problem solve and innovate
without uh different perspectives for
example i mean as i mentioned i came
from a fulfillment our fulfillment
centers and so my kind of knowledge and
awareness of our physical processes adds
i think a lot to the discussion um where
somebody else might come at it from
um kind of a more theoretical approach
or from a really strong product emphasis
um
it allows us to kind of uh share ideas
um and that
i mean i'm using diversity as a very
broad term in terms of background um but
also uh the the kind of traditional
views of diversity including
kind of female black
latino latina
native american et cetera so all of
these different perspectives bring a lot
a lot to the table
i agree
that
definitely agree that diverse teams
bring different uh perspectives and uh
to the table but also i like to think
that uh we need to support these diverse
teams in ways that allow them to work in
you know in ways that support their uh
their style their um
their the in the way that that they make
them collaborate best
for example scheduling meetings in way
that enable
work like balance or um
balancing synchronous and asynchronous
asynchronous collaboration
yes thank you all
and let's stay with this topic of
diversity and innovation at amazon for a
bit i'm curious are you able to share
any examples or anecdotes uh between
diversity and innovation
yeah i think um you know if you look at
um
myspace in terms of
cross-border transactions you can
imagine that every shipment that amazon
global logistics handles is touched by
stakeholders across different countries
like at least i would say four to five
different countries and different
backgrounds
and we have to consider uh that when
we're building our products that uh that
it has to scale globally
and it has to also accommodate a range
of cultural preferences in terms of how
our customer customers would like to
interact with us
for example
our customers in europe tell us that
they prefer reliable email support
but our asia-based customers wish
for instant support and they prefer
mobile friendly channels and this has
influenced a diff a differentiated
support strategy within our customer
service environment
um another example is a content heavy
marketing fire is more effective through
wechat channels
as a sales strategy in china
versus in europe
where we have to have
a portal with very clearly defined
sections for help content and promotions
and that and the same applies for our
us-based customers where they their
preference is going into a portal
getting their information there where
our china-based customers or our
agent-based customers prefer some kind
of push methodology that is content
bridge through
existing channels that they have
so these different
understanding these different cultural
nuances is really really important as we
think about building our products and
being innovative accommodating um uh
diverse backgrounds and making sure that
uh that they kind of meet the hearts and
minds of the customers exactly uh where
they where they want us to be
and and this is a very interesting
question you know amazon fosters an
environment which encourages different
ideas and approaches to solving problems
we have found that incorporating input
from a diverse group of individuals has
allowed us to develop very unique
solutions to very complex problems
further this solution must be able to
address all of the difference between a
different parts of the country and in
all the different countries in the world
that have been underground operations
so to do this it's important to have a
group of scientists with a variety of
background experiences and nationalities
in the last mile as i've seen we have
folks with over 15 different
nationalities we also have found that
each university has strengths in
different areas and incorporating
scientists from a variety of different
universities but it's an important
dimension to our team and help us think
bigger and innovative faster
thank you
very interesting um let's talk for a
second about amazon as an employer from
your perspective what grounds amazon is
a leader in diversity and inclusion
i think
from my perspective
is is the way that amazon um or amazon's
philosophy around building mechanisms
versus good intentions
so if you take the topic of um dei um
we've really inculcated that into our
daily conversations
and we use existing mechanisms to do
that for example
when when we do start a meeting
we
we provide
diversity tips
to ensure that that
one that's top of mind when we're
entering into meetings
uh
two that
kind of opens up discussion around the
topic and people can identify with it
and three
at the the reinforcement component
becomes
becomes really high because sometimes
these these tips are um are either
repeated or it's uh brought forward from
a different perspective and people can
identify with it so so it's really good
you know amazon builds out these
mechanisms rather than just having good
intentions and that is to me is a great
example of how i really ingrain it in in
in just the way we do things on a daily
basis i think the other example that i
think is also really good in terms of
what makes amazon as a leader in this
space
is it's not you know not only are we
saying that this is important to us but
we've actually brought it into our
leadership principles with one of our
latest ones being the striving to be the
world's best employer
uh where where every single day us as
leaders have to work to create a safer
more productive um
high performing and more inclusive
environment and and for those that know
amazon the leadership principles is um
is something that that we we live by
every single day
and it becomes the basis of the way that
we run meetings it becomes the basis of
the way that we evaluate performance
um make trade-off decisions uh and so
forth and i think that those those two
examples to me are great indications of
where diversity is um is not just kind
of a
an intention but it is really um
something that we all firmly believe in
and we we measure our own our
performance against that every single
day
i think you're muted
thank you so much i really appreciate
that and
i absolutely agree with the comments
you've made and i would like to explore
that a bit further and look at the flip
side of the coin so we all sometimes
have these moments in our careers when
you know things don't go right our way
and i'm curious can you share a personal
moment when innovation
was blocked because of non-diverse
thinking or non-diverse environment
yeah i actually have an example um
my team was uh was working on basically
a a product where we wanted to identify
the best way of kind of sourcing
inventory from uh various vendors uh for
example
we can order it in a pallet so we are
ordering enough units to
make up a full pallet or a truckload we
can order enough units to get a full
truckload or direct or import it from
another country etc um and so where we
wanted to basically
identify kind of the optimal sourcing
program for every kind of vendor asin or
a vendor product kind of combination
um that we're currently sourcing from
and the product manager working on that
they went to
one scientist in in the org who happened
to uh have a strong emphasis on ml
and that scientist said we should solve
this with an ml approach we should pull
historical costs historical kind of um
sourcing uh information and basically
run it through an ml model and it will
predict uh based on the you know the
various features for for this other for
these other asins that maybe don't yet
have some other sort of strategy
um and so that's that's the direction
that we went and and it was um i think a
mistake only getting that one
perspective um and getting that one
perspective from somebody with with a
you know just one specific type of uh or
one primary focus area
um so as they went through the process
um basically they identified that
uh one we were missing a lot of we
didn't have you know deep rich data um
there were a large pool of asians that
are products that we
had no kind of historical data on in
this context
and then two we were constantly coming
up with new sourcing programs and new
ways of kind of
getting inventory and in order to
incorporate in this model we would need
all this historical data um and so we've
now identified that we may we're now
assessing a few other options including
like more of a simulation
approach to it
um etc and and honestly i really believe
like if we had just kind of networked
this idea more broadly got more
perspectives on the problem you know
eight months ago we would be in a
completely different place so now we're
kind of delayed on having the right
solution here and that's eight months of
work like really really truly important
work um
and so you know i think it's a good
lesson for for the team for myself
um but i've also seen instances where
the you know having like we we have the
diverse stakeholders and perspectives in
the room and it's really driven benefits
um even you know early during covert we
were prioritizing
um
kind of essential inventory into our
network
and having diverse perspectives in that
equation meant that we weren't just kind
of prioritizing the the top stuff that
customers were looking at but that we
were also uh focused on
a fully inclusive kind of prioritization
of essentials
so essentials for kind of
um every kind of human not not just uh a
kind of single type of human so um i've
seen it go both ways
thank you stephanie for sharing that
and a question i guess uh for anybody
who wants to take this one
can you speak about what do you like
most about amazon and what is it that
you're excited about
all right i can take that
what i like the most is is the ability
to innovate
in order to innovate you have to
experiment
and as any scientist knows
when you experiment you have to be
willing to accept failure
at amazon we are encouraged to try new
things and to tell fast and their
processors if you are not selling enough
you're not innovating about so by doing
this we are able to produce many new
innovative ideas and one of the
advantages that amazon has is that we
have extensive operations which we can
learn from but also we have you know
very large number of delivery stations
throughout the world which we can run
experiments
yep and in my case uh i'm really excited
and i enjoy the opportunity to learn
from other people from other team
members
it seems like everybody has a super
power right so we work in a team with
people from different backgrounds
economists machine learning
applied scientists
data scientists
research scientists so everybody is
bringing a technical superpower it seems
to the table right and it really is
exciting to
learn from from this
this team
but i also think that
not only people are bringing technical
superpowers to the table they also bring
superpowers that are non-technical so
for example some people are really good
in abstracting a problem to the core
some other people are really good and
writing documents uh some
other team members are very good in
you know earning consensus finding
consensus earning trust
so um
i think uh is really
from my perspective i'm really excited
on learning not only from the technical
side but also you know being in this
type of environment where everybody
brings you know their best and their
superpowers to the table and learning
from from them as well
anyone else
want to chime in on this
let's move on then um
can you talk a little bit about some of
the exciting
innovative solutions or projects that
you have worked on
yeah i mean i um i think in our space um
you know uh in the in the cross-border
transportation space
we are currently thinking through a way
to help
our sellers so our sellers are
have in you know sell through our
different
websites
how they could easily navigate the
import processes to get their inventory
across the borders uh into europe
and really what we want to do is we want
to optimize for the the risk that they
may be
the cost that they may incur
and the service levels uh that that they
need in terms of getting the inventory
into our fulfillment network
and all of that in relationship to
um the the third parties or brokers
customs brokers we use
um to to to manage that that particular
transaction and how they connect better
with the seller um we also have a
another dynamic where
uh there could be lots of replanning uh
in the scenario that that results in
updated requests in terms of this import
transaction
uh you know you've seen some of the
inbound supply chain challenges and and
just delays
put results in maybe different
quantities different dates different
places that the the inventory is
importing into and what are the right
gating mechanisms that we need to put in
place
to help that that transaction between
the customs broker and the seller
these additional constraints increase
the complexity of the algorithms we're
building
this project is taking the approach of
working with brokers who might not have
the technology sophistication to build
these integrations with amazon and what
we're doing is extending our brokerage
ui to them where they could perform the
operations within this particular ui
this this particular tool handles the
authentication access control and task
assignments to eliminate the complexity
of these brokers as volumes increase the
brokers who have the tech sophistication
would be able to integrate through apis
to add additional automation to the
process
and we also want to
make it easy and to onboard into these
different platforms for the brokers
so that um so they can just really sign
up themselves um to this program and in
that way uh we can unblock any capacity
constraints uh or supply chain
constraints and create more flexibility
and resilience within the inbound supply
chain
and at the same time we can
through automation of the automation of
the workflows we can reduce the cost and
reduce the the complexity
by ingesting information at the time
that we onboard both the brokers um and
the sellers so it's a pretty complex
space that marine um you know across
anybody that uh that knows me on this
call knows that um uh you know this is
my world um but but to simplify it and
make it easy for both our service
providers which are the brokers as well
as the importers which are our sellers
to get their inventory um pretty much in
any place in europe
is is really one of the the most
mind-boggling things i uh my team is
working on at the moment to see how we
can reduce the cost and simplify the
process
yep and in our case uh in scott's scott
topline forecasting uh one of the most
challenging uh problems we faced
like i'm sure many other teams was uh
covet right the arrival of kovit and um
how we had to address it and innovate so
um as i mentioned right our team is
responsible for
producing a forecast of demand
for a long horizon about four or five
years into the future
so um
historically right our um our models
were able to you know take you know
trends and seasonality do some sort of
extrapolation and arrive at the forecast
but um
with uh covet right these uh methods
stop working right they were not able to
produce sensible reasonable forecasts
anymore
and i think again to to your question
alexandra um
what was the most exciting and you know
something innovative that we did was
really addressing this so the first
problem we had is that in a very uh
short period of time
we have to focus on try to understand
what were the the dynamics of the
what was driving these changes in demand
right of course we knew it was the
pandemic but how it was manifesting what
was the cost and effect and what how
much it was going to last and how things
were going to move forward was really
what was challenging for us so
you know very quickly we we look at
signals from both from outside and
inside amazon and we develop new models
you know we actually in a very quick uh
period of time we you know pull all
those data sets we align them we analyze
them and we produce a new model that was
as i said uh you know taking into
considerations signals both from outside
amazon like macroeconomic sickness as
well as you know signals that reflected
the health and the the state of our
supply chain so it was really again in
you know exciting and
at some point it was really you know a
very fast-paced activity but i think it
was uh it was great for me to work in a
program like that
i'll share um just you know one thing
that that my team's working on that i'm
uh that's pretty interesting and kind of
challenging for us right now um
uh maybe a little bit of the the
kind of covic theme but um the not kovac
but the global supply chain challenge
theme um
has really started to uh
help us think about kind of inventory in
in new and different ways
um so historically we kind of had this
view that if we were if we order
inventory from a vendor
um that you know they're they're fully
incentivized to to sell it to us so that
we can go on and sell it to our
customers right like that's what vendors
are in the business of doing is making
inventory and getting it um kind of out
to customers um and with the supply
chain challenges what we found though is
that yes like that is still the goal and
kind of what what everybody's working on
but but inventory is constrained
um and so now we're starting to think
about things differently in terms of um
you know are there ways to to kind of
predict how much supply
of inventory is available um maybe
domestically versus how much we could
get if we were ordering it um from
the import channel or ordering it from
the country of origin
and and using some of these predictions
to change how we might buy so maybe we
index more heavily on imports and buy
less domestically
or
we
work to sign up that vendor for a kind
of import relationship rather than just
a domestic relationship
and so starting to like use the
this kind of instance of global supply
chain challenge to to rethink even
long-term um
how
how we can better optimize how we source
inventory um it's it's kind of a
new and interesting challenge with a lot
of
uh you know it's how do you how do you
predict how much a vendor has
domestically for you um is is a super
interesting challenge that we're working
on right now so yeah i agree i mean i i
have found it fascinating since i've
joined amazon um how complex and rich
this problem space is
and my background is also in industrial
engineering so i've been looking at this
these supply chain problems um in the
past and just continue to be amazed by
how many different factors there are to
be considered in this space
and uh let's talk about interns at
amazon and i think this is a topic that
will be of interest to to our audience
um and
i'm curious if you could go back to when
you were a student what would you tell
yourself from this perspective and in
particular
do you have any advice for the minority
students
who are starting their careers
well i'll um i mean i can kick off um
with some of my perspective um maybe not
not in terms of um
advice but maybe just perspective um
is that you know within amazon
internships are extremely valuable for
our future leaders and um and and i
think the great thing is is that you
typically do not work
uh on um on deliverables that the
business is already signed up for but
you you have have the luxury of working
on things that are um a little bit more
think big
items uh that help us shape our thinking
of the future
um
the the the challenges is that some of
that comes with a lot of ambiguity so so
as you as you think about taking and
embarking on an internship within amazon
you know be prepared to um kind of have
a high level problem that you're trying
to solve for um
and then and then use a lot of your um
uh own intuition
and data gathering capabilities to to
kind of narrow it down
to exactly what the what the problem is
um
i'll give you an example is that uh last
year
uh we
uh wanted to see if um
simple contacts within our space you
know contacts from our customers could
be automated through natural language
processing but we really just had no
experience in building
any of the these capabilities in terms
of you know voice or chat
bots
so so we tasked our intern
with this particular problem
and this this particular intern didn't
have any tech background in this
particular space um and he he had to
kind of figure out the vagueness of this
problem and and really what what it is
that he's trying to solve for
um and he really went and solved it in
chunks you know so so he looked at what
are the things what are the sub
components of this how to prioritize it
and then choose the battle that that you
want to fight which is um just the proof
of concept chatbot
um with limited tech resources so we
really didn't have a lot of tech
resources to support that um that
particular solution but he managed to do
that he managed to bubble it down
all within
three months
and i think coming in with that bias for
action uh being comfortable with
ambiguity
uh and um asking for help when you need
it is really the key to success for any
internship
um and and then
eventually you know that that both both
your performance and your idea may may
actually result in additional funding
for the following year and something you
can drive which is in fact what has
happened with this particular example so
i think it's a great example of of being
able to come into um an area that that
maybe you don't know a lot about maybe
maybe the subject is a little bit vague
to you but really creating chunkable
components where you can actually
address one problem at a time
and then and then and then coming up
with a solution uh that's that's
plausible and feasible uh in future so
that would be uh my advice in terms of
how to handle um the the internship
now in the in the last mile we have had
the internship for the last couple of
years and i can tell you that working
with insurance have been absolutely
rewarding experience
in amazon we treat interns like new
hires
and they're up to that experience
scientists
uh they're asked to find a problem
unlike anybody else in amazon they are
you have to work partners from the
customer need
to develop an appropriate solution
in this process they want to find
the inputs and the success metrics and
they propose a solution that is back it
up with good hard data and then present
the results
in some cases we have actually
implemented some of the internal
solutions into life operations
uh
and the goal is not only to challenge
them too hard and to solve hard
real-world problems
but also
get them to a level where they want to
come back when they finish the big weeks
in fact in the last month we have
several interns that are now part of the
team
thank you and i i agree i found actually
that what impressed me the most i get
and i can speak as a reasonably new hire
at uh at amazon
uh what impressed me as
in the way that we structure internships
for our interns is that we strive for
each one of them to be a complete
project so something that a person can
own from beginning to end
that they can put on their resume as a
completed project
something that we strive actually to use
in practice
something that probably will be a new
idea so in many ways
these internship projects are really
very interesting and
we provide our interns with a lot of
support we want them to be successful we
want what they've been investigating to
be something we can continue to use in
the long term so overall i find that you
know a lot of our interns are very happy
and like we're happy about that so it
works both ways and just today actually
we had a launch announcement for a
dashboard that was completed by our
summer intern
and this intern was a second year at
university so you can
imagine that there was a lot of very new
very new technologies that he came in
with
contact with for the first time and you
know we were able to support him
and uh you know get it to the point that
something that we can actually keep in
use so i'm just very proud of how that
worked out and one uh one advice i would
give from my perspective to our interns
is to not not shy away from being a
little bit greedy like look
look for what you can take away from the
experience try to learn as much as you
can
try to meet people you know learn from
them ask them about their own experience
uh because you know all of that is
provide some enrichment and hopefully
you know some useful context in the
future and also helps you evaluate if
that if the environment is right for you
and you can make make better decisions
um you know in the future when you
choose your future workplace
and i would like to highlight something
very quickly uh here so the point of
ambiguity right that was brought earlier
it so it seems like when um especially
in the context of internships when you
know
time
is bounded and there's so much pressure
right um
layer that that you know interns will be
facing a business problem a real world
problem right and
those problems usually come with at
least a small amount of ambiguity right
and that creates a lot of anxiety but
ambiguity is really a characteristics of
of the business right and that's why you
know that's that's why companies have
you know all these teams of um
scientists right trying to resolve that
uh to to uh you know crystallize the
solutions for ambiguous problems even
defining the problem is really making
progress so as an intern right
especially in the early parts of the of
the project you will see that there's
probably a little bit uh
um
you know maybe sometimes a lot of sync
what it seems a lot of ambiguity right
but that's really a characteristics of
the of the problems that you know
businesses face
yes thank you everyone
and let's talk a little bit about what
is new and exciting
in the optimization space at amazon
and also if you want to build on the
previous question about how you can
overcome barriers to be successful if
you have any other thoughts you can add
to that
yeah i was going to say i think um
i talked a little bit about a specific
thing in myspace but if you look really
broadly at what we're doing at amazon i
mean you've probably seen one of our
thousands of prime trailers with the
kind of amazon smile on the side but you
may not have seen that there's actually
also a solar powered gps
device on on top of that trailer that
allows us to track every
um asset across the network
we know exactly where they are and we're
able to use that gps to help address
defects before they impact customers
we also once the trailers get into our
yards we pair that gps with vision
systems that recognize the license
plates
um they create an ability for us to have
a touchless check-in process where
there's no contact between kind of the
guard checking in and
the driver that that's driving that
trailer which has been a big asset
during covid
um and then behind all the scenes we
also built state-of-the-art routing uh
algorithms for aircrafts and and trucks
um they evaluate trillions of
permutations to optimize our network
in fact we were actually awarded the
informs prize in recognition for
long-standing application of science to
our logistics so i mean i think overall
like we we continue to innovate and use
kind of optimization
in order to
build a better network for our customers
um in terms of kind of overcoming
barriers none of these things were
accomplished kind of
uh easily i think everything has hit
roadblocks i talked about a project
earlier in my team that's you know now
kind of
eight months delayed um but it's about
kind of learning from that um
learning from that opportunity learning
from the mistake
uh and then going
at it from a different angle or
improving so it's not about um
kind of giving up and saying like if
like we still really value the idea and
we need a different approach to get
there um so that kind of fail fast
mentality although i'd say eight months
is probably uh not necessarily failing
quite as fast as we would have liked to
um
but we use that to continue to overcome
barriers and to um
to kind of re-approach problems
yeah and i think that's a really
important point i think even if we're
successful we're still continuing to
iterate on our ideas and make them
better so
definitely agree with that
okay i think that brings us to the end
of our conversation today so first of
all thank you
to all of our panelists for allowing us
to get a glimpse of the challenging
problems you're working on in your space
and for sharing how you encourage
diversity on your teams
and thank you
to everybody watching for attending our
conversation today
for more info
and if you'd like to learn about
opportunities at amazon you can actually
email us at
informs2021 at amazon.com
and also please visit amazon.science and
you can stay up to date on our most
recent news and announcements
and thank you all and enjoy the rest of
the conference
you